welcome to the world's largest medicine
galleries
home to over 3,000 amazing objects
spanning centuries and continents what
you'll see is both extraordinary and
familiar globally significant and deeply
personal revealing our endless quest to
better understand the human body when
you enter into the galleries you'll be
greeted by self-conscious Jean a
sculpture by Marc Quinn inspired by the
tattooed body of model Rick Genest and
it stands at the gateway of Medicine and
bodies which explores how the search to
understand more about the human body has
transformed medicine expanding our
knowledge of the body from learning how
post mortems are conducted to ever
closer observations understanding the
body on a microscopic scale and
revolutionary technologies such as the
world's first MRI scanner that allowed
us to examine the mysteries of the human
body without resorting to surgery and as
you move through the gallery you'll come
face to face with a selection of
historic objects collected by Henri
welcome like this medicine chest used by
Captain Scott in the Antarctic and
marvel at some stranger things too in
this gallery we examine the core purpose
of medicine treating people
from the ancient practice of trepanning
skulls to leech jars blood transfusions
in the trenches and the UK's first
robotic surgery and no visit to the
gallery can be complete without stepping
inside this real Victorian pharmacy to
learn more about poisons and how to make
your own pills in medicine and
communities we examine health challenges
faced by groups of people and society
from deadly epidemics to the birth of
the NHS and how our behavior can affect
our health this is a scale model showing
what a state-of-the-art Hospital would
have looked like in the 1930s the model
toured the country where it was viewed
by thousands it contains tiny individual
tiles and the bed sheets are made of
handkerchiefs that were donated by Queen
Mary
in faith hope and fear we examine the
cultural site of Medicine the faith that
we put in our treatment and in our
doctors and our hopes and fears about
our own health these are just a few of
the objects and stories for you to enjoy
in medicine the welcome galleries here
at the Science Museum in London